explor bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin alors aujourd'hui
devrait être le dernier jour des
négociations post break site
que peut-on imaginer comme scénario à la
fin de la journée on peut tout imaginer
ce que rien n'est encore réglé on n'est
jamais à l'abri de surprises surtout
dans les négociations qui se passe les
coulisses pour que ces l'oise mais je
pense que l'on comprend pas assez en
fait que le le terrain de jeu de cette
décision et dans la tête de boris
johnson et il faut se rappeler que nous
restions une seule était un tour à tour
où quelqu'un de très pro européens il ya
dix ans une folie de quitter le marché
unique
donc le pays s'apprête justement à face
à dans l'entente de trois semaines il
avait écrit deux éditoriaux parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas à se décider s'il devait
soutenir le break site ou s'y opposer il
a écrit deux éditoriaux avant de prendre
sa décision
en fait tout se joue dans la tête de
bolton ou parce qu'il faut comprendre la
seule question qu'il intéresse vraiment
c'est pas tellement le bien-être de ses
citoyens
c'est l'ambition politique devant
johnson donc à mon avis il a vraiment
une décision à prendre aujourd'hui c'est
de savoir si le fait accepter la chance
d'accord un audit il avancera sains
propres ambitions politiques
jusqu'à mon regard de nos deals lors de
ces négociations qu'elle serait
concrètement les conséquences pour le
royaume uni et pour l'union européenne
très divisée d'après loire tout va se
faire en direct mais il y à des tarifs
d'abord les choses qu'on pouvait les
marchandises ont coûté plus cher puisque
c'était quoi justal jusque là c'était 47
ans ou la grande bretagne étaient dans
le même marché
c'est à dire pas tarifs padouan pas le
contrôle à la douane pour les produits
britanniques et dans l'autre sens aussi
donc s'il n'y a pas de dignité dit qu'il
quant au centre sur le sol agneaux
vous donner un petit exemple sur le
boeuf 6 des produits laitiers dont les
produits des deux parties vont coûter
plus cher
il va y avoir énormément de problèmes on
voit déjà dans les embouteillages de ce
coup les camions et ça va affecter
beaucoup plus les britanniques qui
comptent sur leurs marchandises pour se
faire marcher sur le fait que des
centaines de mexicains de camions
passent sans être contrôlé alors là tout
d'un coup ci la composent agne n'est
plus du tout dans le marché unique et la
patte de d'accord avec l'union
européenne il va y avoir d'énormes
embouteillages et beaucoup de
manquements surtout à court terme cette
interview et l'inter attendait dans les
supermarchés britanniques donc inflation
et moins de produits
on voit aussi que la royal navy a
commencé à prendre ses dispositions
puisque des bateaux ont été déployés ils
s'attendent eux aussi en mode il ça
c'est un peu du n'importe quoi si je
peux me permettre puisque c'était sous
le titre de quelques-uns de ce que
j'appelle les pitbulls propres excite
presse britannique
il faut savoir que les dispose déjà
c'est pas 4 6 2 plus éventuellement deux
autres qui sont en maintenance de ces
bateaux qui sont censés patrouillé toute
les eaux britanniques pour contrôler des
pêcheurs il existe déjà donc faut jamais
oublier le rôle de la presse
75% des journaux britanniques étaient
mais férocement pour le break site
qu'avant les titres insultant
aujourd'hui sur la chancelière merkel
pour se rendre compte que ce n'est pas
une presse très fiable surtout quand il
s'agit du du boxing la pêche la pêche
vous savez la pêche représente
exactement le même chiffre d'affaires la
même importance pour l'économie
britannique que le grand magasin harrods
au sens de l'ombre donc c'est une
question un peu identité amon avis c'est
pas tellement le coeur du problème et
des britanniques leur marine est née
parce qu'elle était donc la marinade
autre chose à faire en ce moment où des
patrouilles et toutes les eaux
britanniques pour projet d'en chasser
quelques quelques chalutiers français ou
autre pour revenir à abhorrer ce johnson
on a l'impression que le premier
ministre britannique
souffle le chaud et le froid ont
l'impression aussi qu'il est brouillée
lui-même dans ce qu'il voudrait faire
est ce qu il veut finalement un divorce
brutal ou plutôt voilà une séparation à
l'amiable mais je pense que le problème
c'est qu'il sait pas ce qu'il veut il
écoute comme beaucoup d'autres
responsables politiques
il écoute sa dernière personne qui a
frappé à sa porte donc le premier de
boris johnson c'est qu'il est il a un
parti où il ya une aile conservatrice
très anti européenne
parce que si tout se dépassent pour sur
la souveraineté
parce que pour les stones syndic il faut
qu'on reste souverain govou choix est
bien moindre deal commercial ou traité
international comporte de toute façon le
fait c'était un peu de souffle t il à
vis de quelqu'un d'autre je ne comprends
pas moi-même comme beaucoup de
britanniques ces problèmes il avait de
la souverainté ici on signe un accord
avec un autre pays
quelque part on se dit bon je suis un
peu moins souvent mais on a un accord
comme un de ceux que les britanniques
terre c'est l'accès au plus grand marché
de puits pour marché prospère du monde
le marché unique de l'union européenne
d'innombrables chômeurs beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vont faire faillite
c'est ça la contrepartie de ces bacs
sitter qui le harcèlent depuis depuis
son aile conservatrice
merci beaucoup d'autres cas alex taylor
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journal et ses
spécialités questions européennes